hey youtubers it's Charlie you guys have
been asking me to do my Legend of Korra
Q&A for so long I decided it was finally
time so we've actually got a little bit
of news since I did my last book 3 video
the sound designer Ben wind is going to
be releasing a new original album
there's no official release date on that
yet I know a lot of you been asking
about the book to soundtrack 2 but
that's actually in the questions that I
picked also if you didn't see it last
week I started doing weekly anime club
videos this week we'll be talking about
Miyazaki films I'll be posting that
video later tonight be sure to subscribe
to get it
it's just attempting to fill the holes
left in our chest until Korra comes back
just like last time I picked 20 of your
questions so here we go let's get
started number one in justice warrior
241 asks who do you think the new
villain is going to be and what type of
bender will we see Toph and her children
so great Delilah implied in a radio
interview that she would be playing a
evil or at least a bad female
waterbender
a lot of people think that that's going
to be the villain I actually think
there's going to be a bigger villain
than that so that person that great ol
Isle villain might be our medium bad the
creator's kind of implied that the big
problem at book 3 the core is going to
have to solve will not be related to her
bending abilities so whoever the big
villain is it's probably not going to be
a bender as for Toph we haven't seen her
grave so you can assume that she's on
walkabout like Zuko or if she's living
with her family in the earth Kingdom
book threes gonna be all about the earth
Kingdom so even if we don't see Toph
we're gonna meet a lot of the other
beifong's question number two jelly
beans 7 8 5 4 asks can korra go into the
spirit world and find her past lives
like Aang did so right now I would say
that's actually the only way she's gonna
be able to talk to her past lives they
haven't really fully explored what
happens to people after they die you
know if they go to the spirit world
indefinitely or if they can go somewhere
else
so until confirmed otherwise let's just
assume that they're on the other side of
that portal somewhere question number 3
Alan Michael asks do you think we'll see
a new series after a Korra book 4 and a
new avatar so Nickelodeon has only
ordered through series 4 so obviously
they're not gonna make any big
announcements probably until we see
series 4 but they are supposedly working
on an avatar movie no matter what
happens though there's always the comic
books question number 4 Marvel el-masri
asks when will they release the book to
soundtrack they haven't announced an
official date yet but it'll be some time
before the premiere of book 3 which I'm
expecting you know late spring early
summer so I would expect sometime within
the next couple of months by the way
they also put all those soundtracks on
Spotify so you'd be able to listen to
him totally for free question number 5 j
jo allen asks
can you explain what happened to Zuko's
mom so during the search they actually
find Zuko's mom or Zuko finds Zuko's mom
and she's changed her face changed her
identity changed her memories so Zuko
does not confront her because he sees
how happy she is question number six
James Caan asks who's got the balls to
tap Toph beifong so you're talking about
beifong father that's a really common
question the current top candidate is
the Duke then there's you know someone
we haven't met yet like a new character
and then three the other theory is that
she's adopted we won't really find out
until book three premiers question
number seven dark winter asks what would
you like to see in book three
honestly I'd like to see you know more
core fire ferrets I'd like to see
Malcolm Bowlin become more central to
the main plot they kind of got stuck in
capital city and book to dealing with
the Vorik storyline look if you saw the
dwarves during The Hobbit the way they
work together and fight together it'd be
really fun to see a fire ferret scene
like that question number eight Tommy
Shan asks will they go deeper into the
concept of energy bending so I know what
you're asking will they give us like a
granular detailed explanation of how
energy bending works and no I don't
think they will just because you really
need to have a lot of experts in that
field of bending around and the only
person who could really do that is the
lion turtle and we probably won't see
another lion turtle until book four at
least that's what I'm hoping to see in
before question number nine is agog and
asks do you think they'll make an
episode where corn asami have to help
each other so a lot of the secondary
characters don't get really big
storylines so I don't expect Asami to
get a lot of extra scenes they will mix
and match the pairings book the book you
know they kind of mix and match you know
odd couples together so like I'm really
hoping that Bolin gets matched up with
lin beifong's so that he can learn
metalbending if you do really want to
see some more Asami Korra I would
recommend you write some fanfiction if
it's not too gross I will totally give
you a shout-out on my channel question
number 10 Matthew Livas asks do you like
last airbender or korra better so I try
to stay free from comparisons like that
because korra you know needs to get
through book four before you can really
make an accurate comparison I will say
that I like the animation style the
studio Mir has been doing better than I
like the animation on Last Airbender
question number eleven Time Lord tenant
asks who would win in a fight Toph
beifong or the weeping angels
interesting question so if you're not
familiar the weeping angels are made out
of stone they're basically like you know
living things in stone they can move
whenever people can't see them so in
order for a top to be able to keep them
from moving
she'd have to continuously pound her
feet on the grass
be like running in place in this fight
and if they were able to scare her they
could knock her off balance and they
would get her immediately so as long as
Toph could continuously pound her feet
on the ground and you know transmit
those sound waves into her visual cortex
she could totally dominate them question
number 12
Adam tolentino asks what was your least
favorite thing about book 2 so I did
like book 2 a lot but my least favorite
thing would be the amount of time they
dedicated to you know developing the
secondary characters one of the big
problems on Korres is that you know they
have like half the amount of time to
dedicate to these other characters that
last airbender did so I would like to
see some of the secondary characters get
more scenes you know either in the comic
books or in some digital shorts you know
anything at all even tumblr fanfic
question number 13 christine samara asks
if the creator's ever did an animated
movie which characters would you want to
see all of them of course so one of the
cool things about it like a 90-minute
movie or an animated movie is that they
have extra time to give these extra
characters and I you know I just got
done talking about how I feel like the
secondary characters don't get a lot of
time so they have extra time for say
like flashbacks or flash-forwards but in
all honesty I would like the story to
move forward so it would either be a
core story or it would be you know the
next avatar after that that being said
you know from a budgetary standpoint
they would probably pick Korra just
because most fans are familiar with
Korra right now question number 14
Lily Ellen kitten asks do you think the
earth Queen will be beifong's sister I
think that the earth Queen is going to
be this new opal character played by
Alyson Stoner
so I don't think she's going to be
related to beifong but I do think that
the beifongs were going to be you know
the most powerful family of the city so
this'll be really tied up in the
politics question number 15
Sara Johansson asks what happened to
Zuko so it's kind of implied that he's
gonna walk about now I do not expect to
see him in book 3 but it would be really
awesome to see him make a cameo in book
4 there's nothing stopping him from
coming back and helping Korra question
number 16 sweet kitty 0 13 asks variety
was saying the Paramount dedicated a big
budget to planning a bunch of animated
movies in 2012 and last airbender was
one of their ideas what does this mean
so what this means is is that the
creators have probably had a pitch
meeting with Paramount and they've
expressed a mutual interest in you know
possibly making an animated movie that
doesn't mean that they have a story that
doesn't mean they have a date it just
means that both parties are thinking
about it
question number 17 Ivo a bull Dez asks
do you think that bolin will ever learn
metal band
I'm actually hoping that he learns
metalbending in this book because it's
an earth Kingdom book so where else
would you learn metalbending obviously
he has to learn it from beifong or
someone that beifong taught to metalbend
so I'm really hoping to see some
hilarious bolin beifong scenes in book 3
question number 18
Randall Fisher asks are they going to
deal with Korra being cut off from her
past lives yes that's actually gonna be
a big part of the plot especially you
know before they find out whatever the
you know big problem courts gonna have
to solve during the season is the big
problem is not going to be that past
life thing it'll be something that
happens in the earth Kingdom because
they wouldn't travel there unless
something really important was happening
question number 19 roberto mallero asks
are we ever going to learn how and I
it's actually kind of implied that he
died of natural causes because
everyone's kind of so peaceful about it
I feel like if he would have died from
you know say like being murdered or if
it would have been a big battle they
would have talked about it during book 1
question number 20 Adventure Club asks
will we see any digital shorts before
the premiere of book 3 so yes I'm
actually hoping to see a beifong digital
short they might not do quite as many
they did a three-part one before the
premiere book two I don't think they'll
do quite that many though thank you so
much for submitting your questions guys
this was a lot of fun remember I'm gonna
be posting my anime club video later
tonight be sure to subscribe to get it
I'll probably post my space dandy
episode 2 video tomorrow morning thank
you so much for watching right now click
here to get my last book 3 video and
click here to get last week's anime club
video thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives